head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
from the daily wire Superstar Katy Perry
confirms she's voting for Rick Caruso
this is a guy he's technically a
Democrat but he was a republican until
he decided like a couple weeks before he
decided to be uh is that what happened I
think he was a republican then he's like
I'm gonna run Democrat switched parties
then ran and now you got this big old
picture of Katy Perry voting for a what
is effectively a republican so what does
that mean does that mean there's there's
hope she's got G is that Jesus said to
it on her wrist I mean I'd be willing to
bet that she's probably votes Republican
in secret anyway
she might the other thing with Rick
Caruso is that he owns The Grove Mall
which is the best mall in LA and it's
super duper clean
um I think so so it's probably awesome
yeah we should probably fact check that
but I think he does so the thing is is
that the Optics of this perfectly clean
like the most clean part of LA and then
kind of juxtaposing that against the
rest of La that's getting a little bit
overrun it's uh just the Optics of it
just feels good let's just make sure
that I got that correct Caruso
Affiliated owns The Grove and the Grove
is so beautiful and everybody in la lo
loves it so it's like this beautiful
clean place so just seeing that is the
perfect optics for somebody I don't
think there's anything that everyone in
New York City loves we have a Central
Park it's yeah Central Park I lived in
New York City I grew up in New York City
I think everyone loves Central probably
that might be the only thing but the
Grove is so clean so this is perfect
it's clean it's orderly everybody loves
the Grove to The Grove but now the cops
arrest you and give you tickets if
you're there past like 11 p.m or 12 p.m
in New York City Central Park which is
absolutely Draconian and we're back to
the thing where you're where if you're a
woman walk talking by yourself you're
not walking through the park after dark
like we are back to that I was talking
to a friend of mine the other night and
she's like I don't walk through McCarran
Park after dark anymore well there was
that there used to be no issue at all
that young woman at uh worship Columbia
yeah she got murdered by those like
teenagers or whatever yeah and she's not
the only one I mean teenagers are out
there killing people there was a young
man on the subway 14 years old who was
murdered by a gang of girls stealing his
iPhone
14. wow they murder him they stabbed him
to death and he didn't know them the
they were not at all connected yeah in
New York City when you need help from
the cops they're not there and many
times there's so many years
when you when you are by Trump Tower and
you want to complain about black lives
matter in the street the police are
there to arrest you yeah of course yes I
was finishing my statement there in
particularly also talking about how if
there's a ticket to be written they're
there they're gonna do it but if you
need help I know multiple instances
where people were getting shot stabbed
or beaten and the cops were literally
standing by and watching not doing
these violent criminals who are
committing these crimes are are let out
of jail because it's only fair right I
mean you know a cash bail is is holding
someone unreasonably right yeah there's
a guy there's a guy named there's a guy
named
I want an answer to this this the
statement what if you have someone
committing crimes in New York should we
extend to them our principles of letting
them out of jail instead of or should we
hold them that's not the same Market I
don't have that principle of letting
people out of jail so so so we locked up
if they commit crimes but you got to
prove it right you can't just arrest
someone without proving it before a jury
of their peers okay but so that's you
know do you believe that people should
be should only be imprisoned if they're
proven guilty Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
uh probably not I think probably you
should be able to sit in jail waiting
for your trial if you're a violent
person so not anything committed a
violent crime so so the idea is the
government shouldn't be allowed to put
you in jail
unless they've proven you've committed a
crime but what we've done to decide is
we've recognized there's actually like a
a gradient here it's not absolute and
that is some people are so dangerous we
actually decide even before we've proven
it we're going to remand them and not
release them now that's a challenge I
have an issue with that because my
values are you the government should not
be able to put you in a box and lock it
up unless they've proven Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt you've actually done
something wrong because innocent people
do suffer because of this however I also
recognize letting the letting people out
in this regard results in rampant
violent crime and I don't know what the
solution is but I can tell you cashless
bail has only made things worse yeah
they were supposed to do cashless bail
only for non-violent offenders and it
hasn't really worked out that way
because people will be led out of jail
and two days later they're back in
because they've killed somebody they've
seen this happen in Chicago and New York
and all over the place and that means
the solution is people get put in jail
for extended periods of time because the
system can't handle it even if they're
they're not proven guilty that's a
that's a problem that is a problem and
the court system should work a lot
faster like you shouldn't be sitting
there having a trial two years after you
did the thing or like you know just
stuck in jail I get that time but that's
like there was a story I saw where a
Starbucks had huge lines going at the
drive-through into the street so the
city voted to ask Starbucks Starbucks
workers to work faster oh nice like if
we don't have if if the city is so Rife
with crime and so dense that the court
systems and the police can't actually
properly adjudicate crimes actually have
bail hearings then the whole system is
just totally screwed up and busting
there's I don't even know how you fix it
so the problem we have now is our values
and this is what the progressives have
been advocating for in cities like like
La New York and Chicago and whatever is
you should not be able to imprison
someone for any any reason I mean that
in the close it's not the legal sense
unless you've proven it and that that
includes a bail hearing but because
there's so much crime you have people
lined up and the judge is like I don't
have time for this you remand you're
violent or a person's like your honor I
argue he's not violent okay fine you can
leave nope no cash bail then they go
murder people again
I think the problem is there is no like
we can be as principled as we want to be
we have a very serious problem we do
have a serious problem and we have crime
Rising even though we have Democrats
telling us that it's just that that's
just I'm mostly in big cities these days
and um I was at Surfside tacos last
night here in DC or just close to here
and uh we got shot at actually last
night I'm not even kidding
everybody's hitting the ground last
night getting a taco I'm like well I'm
gonna go out get a taco with my kids are
going to pick no big deal we all laughed
it off but it happened
um all my kids had to stop a robbery
recently in Los Angeles had to get in a
fist fight the mother of my kids my
buddy Sid got pistol whipped in New York
and ROM for his watch right by piano bar
uh yeah I know right then he got clocked
by another crazy guy uh in weho in Los
Angeles
um you walk down the street in L.A and
it there is a huge homeless encampments
of tents that just run all down Sunset
Boulevard I mean it's getting crazy you
can't walk down the street I don't know
what you're talking about like you can't
walk down the street like the all the
imperments literally really block you
from walking down the side yeah you have
to actually walk on to yeah what he's
saying you have to walk onto Sunset
Boulevard yeah and then you walk by the
encampments Yeah and um they're not look
they're nice they haven't caused any
problems but what if I'm with my kids
I'm not gonna walk by that like if I'm
if I'm walking around the city I you
know and I see like a bunch of homeless
junkies like nodding off I cross the
street I'm not gonna walk by that I'm
not gonna do it I'm not walking by with
my kid and I'm not walking by by myself
like totally you know the risk reward
scenario is just it's just not there
what do we do about this what do we do
we start arresting the open-air drive
markets you know we used to do that
right so when Giuliani came into office
in New York City and like what 93 or
something like that he started cleaning
up City by doing exactly that he was
just started arresting people arresting
people for selling drugs and it was you
know it was pretty severe and I remember
at the time being like what is this but
um the city turned into a paradise
within about 15 years and it was
spectacular to live there yeah that
sounds very effective I get I it sounds
authoritarian it does sound
authoritarian but I mean I think when
you're talking about a big city when
you're talking about millions of people
living on top of one another who need to
have a safe place to walk and you know
Safe Streets safe Parks safe places to
walk around and to do their business and
all of that and this is my argument but
at this point too we have a much
different situation because we're
completely decriminalized marijuana and
this is right so this is my argument
when it comes to people like Ethan and
Kathy Griffin when they're actively
advocating against our rights to free
speech I say they're banned okay good
riddance like if if someone is innocent
in New York City and they get arrested I
hope they are not held and that's why I
don't like the idea of cash bail that a
poor person who's in the wrong place at
the wrong time gets arrested and the
state is just like too bad for you
that's screwed up but now we see what
happens when you have cashless bail
people are being pushed in front of
subway trains people yeah people are
being slashed so I don't know security
versus freedom I lean towards second an
amendment the issue however is you want
to err on the side of stop violence
meaning more innocent people get locked
up or on the side of protecting the
innocent meaning more bad people go free
we tend to err on the side of bad people
going free but in a certain situation
now too at a certain point we just say
if we know the person is violent and
actively sowing like violence
destruction we remand them if you've got
people like you know these these
prominent leftists who are going to
Advocate against speech and cheer for
censorship we say remand them when they
get sponsored I'm not letting them out
that can be adjudicated somewhere else
yeah I mean we have a system that
incentivizes crime uh incentivizes some
of the worst behaviors while making
citizens uh defenseless that's a major
problem that that of course we need to
talk about more because people were able
to defend themselves if people weren't
being prosecuted by George Soros
district attorneys that punish people
for self-defense it would be a totally
different landscape if politicians and
the school system and the education
system weren't incentivizing a lot of
this violent nonsense I don't think we
would be in in this kind of system so I
I think the problem is very complex I
think it can't just be solved in one
simple conversation or in one simple
phrase but at the end of the day I think
the government's making it a lot worse
than that I have I have and more
government wouldn't make it better in my
opinion I have an analogy that I used uh
for Ian you know Ian really loves us
he's in a science
I was imagining living in New York City
and I uh I was imagining when I did live
there I lived on Myrtle and Nostrand in
this apartment building in a small like
700 square foot box with people to my
top left right and behind me and below
me and then I was just like man I can't
play music here you can't you get you
can get an acoustic guitar and you can
play during certain hours you can't play
drums right you can get practice pads or
maybe an electric kit and then put you
know headphones on or something but you
can't be noisy and I started to think
was as people get pushed closer you have
this as an individual you have this
bubble of freedoms around you as you get
further and further away from other
people that bubble grows and grows and
grows where you're no you're not
impeding on anybody else's life
As you move closer and closer to people
the bubble starts getting pressed upon
by other people's bubbles so I I you
know Ian loved as I said it was like
rural people are basically like gaseous
bouncing around all crazy having all
this Freedom having a good time and then
as you move closer and closer to the
city becomes more solid where you
literally can't do anything you can't be
noisy you can't be up too late you can't
blast the stereo you can't have your
guns can't have your guns can't can't
cook stinky Foods because there's too
many people around you you are
solidified in this block that's rigid
and controlled and I think the problem
is there is no ideological or policy
solution to population density there's
none you recognize that if you live in a
big city there's going to be too much
crime because there's too many people
and the police and the courts won't be
able to handle it properly properly so I
just I think it's fair to say there's no
simple solution
well there's been an incentivized
program within the last few decades
pushing people to live in cities wanting
people to live on top of each other yes
I think that kind of lifestyle lifestyle
has been glorified I think there's been
a lot of manipulation to make it seem
like it's trendy like it's cool like a
tip when in reality it's an absolute
hellscape where police officers try to
steal your money to generate revenue for
the state while of course making sure
you're defenseless as the crackhead who
stabs you uh you know as they're
literally sitting there watching you uh
that's life in New York City but that's
life in New York City like that before
it wasn't like well it wasn't like that
in the 90s because I grew up in New York
City in the 90s
it was and then it got changed and got
better it got more authoritarian broken
windows policing yes and crime dropped
Dramatics did it or was it just the
reporting because we also have to
understand here the New York City Police
Department manipulates manipulates the
reporters
yes of course but but I'm saying crime
goes in waves but when there's a program
and and there's been an epidemic of New
York City police officers that have been
downgrading particular crimes to make it
seem like it's not a big issue whether
it's you know uh you know assault it was
simple batteries whether it's robberies
it was just a small petty theft and a
lot of the times police officers got
caught lessening the crimes in order to
make their Precinct look like it was
good and tough on crime when in reality
there was a lot of crime and what
essentially Giuliani did he violated a
lot of people's civil rights but he also
contained the crime in particular areas
uh and essentially pushed it away and it
still continued but only continued in
certain neighborhoods yes that's exactly
right they turned Manhattan into a
glorious playground for The Super Rich
yes yes and for those of us who wandered
about in it thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time